so what we have here is a ball and you
imagine if i take this ball and bounce
it off the table it'll bounce off that
table and if i do that exactly the same
way each time then what will happen is
that it'll hit the same point on the
wall imagine if we had a million balls
we could control it so that each and
every one of them hit the table in
exactly the same way exactly the same
velocity that bounce off and we'd end up
with a
very well defined
dent in the wall
if we then for example just scatter
those balls take them and file them off
at different angles then what you'll
find is that the wall will cover up with
different dents in the wall and we'll
end up with a a sort of random well a
random distribution of dents in the wall
electron is a negatively charged
particle
and it is enormously important
mendeleev
didn't believe in electrons
he thought atoms were solid and you
couldn't break them and weren't made up
of anything else and he believed this
till he died in 1907
but electrons are
enormously important for chemists so now
if we imagine instead of we're in the
real world we shrink everything down so
this ball becomes a an electron or we
can think of this as being an electron
what we actually find remarkably
is that we get these bands
we've got this very well defined pattern
of here where there are lots of of dents
here whether or not
practically none here there are lots of
dents again and those bands have a
well-defined spacing a well-defined
separation why do electrons behave so
differently from little balls and maybe
that's because well actually they're not
little balls there's something different
from little balls what could that be
well let's go down to the lab and we'll
see another experiment whereby we see
these patterns and maybe the patterns we
see in that experiment will help us to
understand really what these electrons
are
all
right when i teach the students in their
first week of coming to university i
tell them about electrons how they
behave in atoms
and they find this is very hard because
electrons if you treat them one way
behave just like a particle
an electron is something a negative
charge that can be transferred between
one atom and another rather like
changing money
but
on the other hand if you want to
understand the structure of the atom
then you have to treat the electron as a
wave
hello george
what we have here is not an experiment
with electrons so we will get to that
what we have here
is an experiment with light in this case
we've got a laser the important reason
we're using a laser enough for example a
light bulb is that in the laser the the
photons of light all come out in step so
we've got an obstacle through which
those photons those little packets of
light
have got to pass and so if you follow
this through you follow the path of
light down here we have the light and
instead of it all piling up what we see
is this pattern exactly like that i was
discussing in terms of the electrons
this is something called a double slit
experiment we have two slits here
the key thing here is that what we have
is light light is a wave that wave is
coming through and it's interfering
constructively destructively to form
this type of pattern the key thing here
is related to how those waves interfere
with each other
but we see exactly
the same pattern in terms of this
these bright spots these dark spots when
we do this experiment with electrons and
that leads us to think well hang on if
we're seeing exactly the same patterns
with photons which are a wave and we
know that as electrons then it leads us
to think well
maybe the electrons are actually not
just little hard balls little billiard
balls they actually have a wave like
nature and the problem
is that
you have to explain the thing
mathematically
and as soon as you
go into the maths the difficulty is
that unless people are very good
mathematicians and i'm not
it's not very clear what the equations
mean
everyday common sense does not allow us
to describe it in simple words the
concepts are too elusive and slippery
for the english language but it has
these particle-like qualities which it
always takes with it such as its mass
its momentum its spin its electron
lepton number and so on and that always
remains so if a particle comes along and
hits something that is always conserved
and this quantity remains the same but
when it hits things it does so as a wave
scattering off things as a or a wave so
all the time it has these two elusive
characters going on
and
i don't know physics when you're 18 is
based on common sense but when you've
gone through all this
somehow you get used to it you don't
actually like it you just get used to it
and learn to live with it and that's the
language that seems to fit
so back in the office what we were doing
was this
considering that if those electrons were
billiard gore-like particles that when
we fire them at something they'll all
pile up in one place or they'll spread
out randomly what we have here is the
actual experiment where we're taking a
sample and we're firing electrons of
that those electrons are bouncing back
from that sample and we're looking at
the pattern they form now if they were
little billiard balls and we wouldn't
expect to see
what we'd expect to see would be a
random sort of splurge of electrons
that's not what we see what we see are
very very well defined peaks and those
peaks and spots um arise from the
wave-like properties of the of of the
electron and what we have here is
instead of having a slit um like we had
with the experiment with the photons of
light what we're using because the
wavelength of where the wavelength of
the electrons is so much smaller is
we're actually using the atoms of a
surface to diffract the electrons one of
the things which
i think perhaps students find
particularly difficult
is that when you're treating the
electron as a wave
you can't really talk about it being
there or there or there because a wave
is everywhere in the volume that you're
considering
and therefore the idea that everything
is very delocalized
is difficult for people to understand
back in 1923 there was a piece of kid
who resembled this that actually gave us
the really the fundamental proof that
electrons had wave like characteristics
and so it was a couple of people called
davidson and germa managed to measure a
pattern just like this that we've got in
here very similar to this and they
realize well hang on that's that's a
diffraction pattern that means that the
electrons must be waves or must have
wave like character